good evening I'm Alexander Alexander
Rose the executive director at long now
foundation thanks for my wife for
starting that applause a few things to
go over before Stuart comes out the
first one is an update on our salon
project renovation at Long now as you
know we haven't been in the cow for a
while and this is the first time here at
SF jazz which is a pretty awesome
theater I see some of you already have
drinks in your seats which is a welcome
change so thank you to SF Jazz for
having us I think we're one of the first
speaking events here and so I'm hoping
it goes it goes well so the as many of
you may know we launched a campaign to
raise money for our salon renovation
just before the end of the year along
with st. George spirits who made some
custom gins and whiskeys for us and
since that time we have been working on
finalizing the plans and getting them
all approved by the Park Service which
has now been done and we came upon a
really interesting opportunity which is
the people that are renovating pier to
the Cowell theater where we have a lot
of these events Oliver and Co are
offering us a discount if we get started
on doing the construction at the same
time they're doing that renovation so if
we get started in June we get a
substantial discount so we're trying to
get to the halfway point of raising the
money for that which is about $80,000
away and so we're about to launch a new
version of the campaign for that that
also includes a bunch new donation
levels starting as low as $10 so $1500
is no longer the the low bar
and we've been working on the design of
this space so that it has a lot more
kind of conversational spaces of chairs
facing each other and as well as being
able to convert into an event for small
events for up to about 70 people
it even has chalkboard robots for
keeping the lung now Twitter stream up
in chalk and the other thing that we are
adding in working with samovar tea
lounge is as as we had the alcohol side
of this that you could kind of buy into
we also wanted a non-alcoholic I dove
this that you could buy into and so we
tried to find a long-term tea and it
turns out there is a tea called puer T
which is aged over decades and they have
found sourced a 1989 vintage puer tea
which is we're going to store on site
just like we do with the the gin and the
whiskey so you can come and your party
leaves come down and we make a pot of
those for you we're about to launch this
new website that has all these different
levels on it including the challenge
coins which are redeemable for one of
our rare drinks that we have a clay
lined tea tumbler that gets better with
age the tea just keeps tasting better in
that clay and the tea itself as well as
a new library that is going to house our
collection our small now small
collection of books on long-term
thinking but what we're going to do is
ask all of you our members to help fill
that out with books on basically the
manual for civilization so the 3,000
volumes that you would want to restart
civilization and it's going to be crowd
curated by you all so I'd like to thank
all of you who got us to 170 thousand
dollars so far and hopefully we can
finish this out by the end of June and
get to the point where we can start
construction thank you very much
[Applause]
so since Stewart is the host of the
series he doesn't really have someone to
introduce him he doesn't really need an
introduction I don't think to this group
but I just wanted to mention a little
bit about having the revive and restore
project here under the long now umbrella
and when Ryan and Stewart first started
talking about this project it was pretty
clear there was a long term project I
mean if you look at the restoration of
the California condor for instance it's
30 years in at least in order to get
from tens of birds to hundreds of birds
so no matter what species we choose even
ones that haven't gone completely
extinct it's a long term project and you
also do long term historical research in
order to figure out how you're going to
go about this so that made a lot of
sense but what has been especially
striking to me is that revive and
restore is not only long-term thinking
in that sense but it's also one of the
first projects about conservation that
isn't just conserving it's creating and
I think that's a really important point
that you know when I look at my three
and a half year old daughter and try and
sell her a version of the future it's
not just you're living in a world with
less you're living in a world where you
can create more and that's really why I
think this project is important and is
important to long now and I know that we
have a bunch of students here from CSU
East Bay which is part of our long kids
program where we're just now starting to
to work with younger students and
they're very interested in this project
and I'm really encouraged to see that
I just saw the future there's gonna be
woolly mammoths back in Siberia in
northern Canada knocking down the
forests helping save us from climate
change and keeping the tundra from
releasing all those gases and bringing
back grass which fixes carbon and people
will say and I thought they would be
bigger
well so we're here in the San Francisco
jazz center Center for music so it'd be
nice to start with some group song I
think no melody don't worry just the
music of time 65 years ago in 1948 there
was created something called the
conservation pledge I give my pledges
American deceiveth faithfully defend
from least natural resource in the
country tariffs all minerals forests
water in the wildlife I was 10 years old
I bought into it completely let me see
if this group likes it try it on for
size foresight after me I give my pledge
as an American
to save than faithfully to defend from
waste the natural resources of my
country its air soil and minerals its
forests waters and wildlife alright
let's just see if we get there he is
you see up okay tonight the subject is
wildlife so I bought it
I majored in ecology at Stanford but
then I wound up spending most of the
later years being a sort of profit for
digital technology always catalog and
elsewhere there was conservation and
biology in there but mainly as a a
person who said these technologies like
digital technology are liberating if you
make them a cell so nowadays I'm doing
that with biotechnology I'll consider
smart phones digital technology liberate
spew like mad well just a few years ago
you had in vitro fertilization starting
to come along in the 80s and people said
oh this is abhorrent this is an
abomination this is people playing God
there's clearly gonna be something wrong
with those children and there's probably
something wrong with the parents who
want to make humans that way and then
they missed the babies and they met the
parents who have been liberated from non
fertility and now in vitro fertilization
probably made quite a few humans in this
group and is one of the normal ways that
we reproduce these days well biotech is
about to liberate conservation or at
least part of conservation and in a
spectacular way because they extinction
is a different kind of death it's bigger
and we didn't really learn that until
1914 when the last passenger
a female named Martha died in the
Cincinnati Zoo this had been the most
abundant bird in the world they'd been
here in North America for maybe six
million years Fox a mile wide before
hundred miles long used to darken the
Sun although Leopold one of the founders
of conservation biology said the
passenger pigeon was no mere bird he was
a biological storm yearly the feathered
tempest roared up down and crossed the
continent sucking up the laden fruits of
forest and prairie burning them in a
traveling blast of life Bird was at
keystone species enhancing the whole
eastern deciduous forest from Canada to
the Gulf from Mississippi to the
Atlantic they were what are called now
ecological engineers animals that create
or modify habitats for other species
either structurally as beavers new or
nutritionally the way salmon to
passenger pigeons did both those things
this was an athletic bird they had two
speeds zero and 60 miles an hour
well those flocks went 60 miles an hour
dodging through trees they went at 60
miles an hour there's one story of a
group of men who are standing around
with their horses and here came a
passenger pigeon being hotly perceived
by a falcon and the passenger pigeon at
60 miles an hour ducked through the legs
hit one of the horses but these birds
went from five billion to zero in just a
few decades what the hell happened well
commercial hunting happened they were
hunted for meat that was sold by the ton
and the problem for them was that the
flocks were so dense that when they came
to earth they could be nabbed by hunters
and netters who had come from all over
by the hundreds and killed the birds by
the tens of thousands and ship
the new trains to the East Coast to be
sold so all of us left after a couple of
decades of that plus losing some of the
forest that was where they lived all of
us left was skins beautiful skins and
museum specimen drawers people did
realize that the same thing was just
about to happen to the American bison
and just in time
the Buffalo were saved but it wasn't
just the passenger pigeons Carolina
parakeet used to light up the backyards
of the whole eastern United States their
vulnerability was compassion if farmer
saw a flock of birds aren't messing with
the apple trees you would shoot a
Carolina parakeet and the other Carolina
parakeets wouldn't fly off they would
stick around and try to help the one
that was injured and that would continue
until the entire flock was killed and we
ran out of Carolina parakeets penguins
abound in the Antarctic but up in the
Arctic their ecological niche was filled
by a another flightless standing around
burden called the Great Auk whose
vulnerability was that it bred on just a
few islands and people go to those
islands and they were hunted for meat
for fat and for feathers for down and
then they were gone there was a Heath in
on the East Coast the people loved was
diminishing to feral cats and maybe
diseased in loss of habitat and when it
finally disappeared a local paper said
what we always say there's no survivor
there's no future there's no life to be
recreated in this form ever again well
I'd happen to a lot of birds and a lot
of mammals an amazing animal was the the
aurochs in Europe which was the American
bison equivalent it used to keep all of
Eurasia from Spain all the way to Korea
somewhat open in biodiverse with meadows
and grasslands documentation on that
goes all the way back to Lascaux caves
one of the most barbless of all animals
was thylacine the tasmanian tiger in
tasmania they were thought to be a pest
killing sheep they weren't but I was a
bum rap nevertheless they were hunted
until there just a few left in zoos just
in time for a little bit of film to be
shot you see that kind of thing and you
just born but hey organize what if you
heard that it might be possible to bring
back some extinct species using the DNA
and their museum specimens and in some
fossils that might be possible for these
birds to fly up out of the museum
drawers and again darken the Sun nice
idea where would you start well first
thing he do is find out if the
biotechnology is actually there is this
just a story we're telling ourselves I
started with my wife Ryan feeling we
were in a business called DNA direct
he'd been working in human genomics for
a while and one of her colleagues happen
to be George church who's one of the
world's foremost synthetic biologists
and George turned out to be fascinated
by passenger pigeons and quite kind of
confident that he knows techniques that
could bring them back so Ryan organised
and George hosted at the V sin stitute
Harvard a meeting Smallman with just a
few conservation ornithologists and
molecular biologists like George and
bioethicists Jones got to have at least
one and fortunately molecular
evolutionary biologist named Beth
Shapiro had already sequenced the
passenger pigeon a few years before all
she really needed
from the specimens that the Smithsonian
was a little bit of tissue from the toe
pad and write down way the hell in there
just need a little pinheads worth is
what's called ancient DNA because once
these specimens are dead the DNA starts
to fall apart ready fragment is
contaminated with a lot of stuff but we
have the techniques now to reassemble
laborious ly but successfully basically
the entire genome of the extinct animal
so then the question is if you can
reassemble the genome can you reassemble
the perc and this is where George church
thinks that you can his book read
Genesis as the chapter on bringing back
extinct species and one of the tools he
would use is the multiplex automated
genome engineering device they developed
at the Reese Institute which is a kind
of an evolution machine basically you
write some DNA you try it out on cells
and what we call organs on a chip and
you race them against each other in a
massive way and then the winners of that
the ones are really successful then you
can try them out on a living organism
now there's a slide of George's it's
kind of slides that scientists show to
each other but the point it's making is
that the precision is so complete now
you get you can make changes right down
at the base pair level there's 1.3
billion base pairs in the genome of a
passenger pigeon 3 billion base pairs in
us over 4 billion base pairs in a woolly
mammoth and the idea is you'll be able
to replace a gene or the variation of
that gene with a different allele so you
could call the technique allele
replacement and what you then might be
able to do is to take genes from an
extinct species you know apart from
doing the sequencing and swap them for
alleles in the closest living relative
of the extinct species
now Jorge points out along the way that
the technology he is working with genome
editing technology basically is
advancing at a rate something like four
times to six times the rate of Moore's
law that's been accelerating like that
since 2005 just in the last couple of
years the cost and the sophistication of
his techniques that are improved 40 fold
so the closest living relative of the
band of the passenger pigeon is the
band-tailed pigeon there's some around
here I saw one last weekend in Bundaberg
there's even that it's a game bird that
can shoot them locally in January about
the Ben tail pigeon living bird hundreds
of thousands of them is basically a
passenger pigeon genetically there's
just a few bits that are band-tailed
pigeon so if you can replace those bits
with passenger pigeon bits you'll have
the living extinct bird back at cooing
with you it won't be perfect but it
should be perfect enough and one of the
things I've been learning in all of this
is the nature doesn't do perfect either
basically everything out there is one
degree of hybrid or another including
incidentally us who are pardoning in to
fall apart nice event
so this meeting in Boston had three
direct results this is by the way I
think how you move things along this is
kind of my report to along now a
membership you know you get something
like this going to do with meetings this
meeting had three direct results one was
that Ryan and I were persuaded that
there was really something here the
passenger pigeon probably was the good
organism to work with in all of this and
within long now he started this thing
nonprofit called revive and restore
extinct extinct species back to life
ecological enrichment through extinct
species for Bible and the idea is that
we would try to move ahead the whole
field of the extinction as a field that
can move ahead responsibly and
specifically push ahead with the
passenger pigeon so a question that
keeps coming up so I do it I bring back
extinct species it'll be expensive and
difficult it'll take a long time it
won't always succeed why bother
but then you have to ask why did we put
so much time in trouble and effort any
motion into protecting endangered
species because the same reasons we'll
apply it to species brought back from
extinction
we want to preserve biodiversity we want
to restore diminished ecosystems we want
to advance the science of preventing
extinctions and it would be nice to undo
some harm that humans have done in the
past as in troops long now which is the
last 10,000 years in the next 10,000
years the 20,000 year now or currently
in the middle of it was over the last
10,000 years that most of the human
caused extinctions occurred and DNA from
those extinctions from most extinct
animals is available to work with as
Alexander pointed out reviving the
animals well you have to move at the
pace of species and habitats continents
basically and climate change so it's a
matter of decades probably centuries
reviving extinct species is a long slow
gradual exciting process that's what we
like to see civil
station stepping up to that kind of
thing a while back we started long down
in 1996 there was another long term
project that was proposed that everybody
thought well a cute idea must be a
metaphor it's not going to really happen
is it this is the 10,000 year clock
being built as we speak in West Texas
[Music]
music from brian eno was on the board
should be here sometime every now and
then something is weird enough and
attractive enough that people say screw
it go ahead and do it and I happened
with the clock
I think it'll happen with some of these
species the second result of that
meeting was that word got around to a
young graduate student and he got in
touch this is somebody named Ben Novak
and it turned out that along with Beth
Shapiro all on his own he had sequenced
the passenger pigeon using money from
his parents and family and friends he
gotten his expertise with ancient DNA
from Hendrik poinar it was one of the
leading experts in that and turned out
he had been obsessed with passenger
pigeons since he was a young teenager
he's got all of 26 so we hired him
full-time and in this photo I took last
year of him at the Smithsonian he's
looking down at none other than Martha
the last passenger pigeon alive Ben's
job is to adjust reality so she is not
the last the third outcome of the Boston
meeting was the realization that there
are scientists all over the world
working on various forms of
de-extinction but they'd never met each
other
National Geographic got interested
because they're celebrating the 125th
anniversary this year and they have a
theory that the last century discovery
was mostly about finding things and they
think that in this century discovery is
mostly about making things so the
extinction they figured fits into that
and they hosted this meeting at their
original building and they're in their
board room actually as a private meeting
about thirty-five scientists molecular
biologists and conservation biologists
coming together to see if they actually
had work to do together
and they decided that they do as pre
rousing George Church said that it
reminded him of the meeting in 1984 in
Alta Utah in which was decided to go
ahead with a Human Genome Project
now one revelation that I had was that
there's a lot of conservation biologists
that aren't waiting for extinct species
to come back they're already bringing
back extinct ecosystems so for example
David Birney over in Hawaii and he's
done enough paleo ecology and their site
in koi to decide that they could bring
back right there in the sink over there
doing the work a piece of ancient Hawaii
all he had to do was eliminate the
invasive plants plant 100 or so native
plants and wait for rare animals to show
up which they did but that success
required finding a surrogate for an
extinct animal called the which was a
tortoise build flightless duck that used
to basically harvest all the ground
cover plants that are mostly invasives
now that volunteers couldn't keep up
with but a land tortoise which is not
particularly invasive and people keep
them as pets and then grow tired of them
as they get enormous so they were
provided for free and they are doing the
job of the extinct animal very well if
somebody wants to bring back the
tortoise build duck then they can
replace the tortoises but in the
meantime the surrogate is working just
fine that's this kind of soft edge we're
discovering in the conservation biology
everywhere folium France Vera is doing
something even more ambitious there was
an article about it in New Yorker a
couple months ago his idea he's got this
place called the Varden opossum and it's
ancient Europe and Netherlands was like
about 20 feet below sea level so if the
dam is ever burst so much for ancient
Europe but he's got
23 square mile area in which is using
her befores like the ancient herbivores
these are HEC cattle and Konak horses
replacing the old tar pan and or ox
until they get them back and the result
is a nature reserve that and once again
the rare species are showing up like the
bearded reading graylek goose the
white-tailed eagle and once upon a time
much of Europe looked like Africa does
now well one part of Europe now looks
like Africa does now and that kind of
thing is going on the leader of all of
the oh and I should mention that the
Oryx is being brought back by Henry Kirk
by cotton and others who are working
with thing remember is that the Oryx is
not a mythical beast last one died in
1627 very well-documented as I show and
they are the parent ancestor of all
domestic cattle basically some of the
domestic cattle are out there's a lot of
varieties some of them are pretty
primitive very Hardy and on Henry's
group is doing is basically back
breeding those guys to go back to the
traits which are well known working with
species like the yeah the Mara mana
Primitivo he looks like he saw a cave
wall and they're bringing back this
animal now Europe is way ahead of North
America in rebuilding wildlife corridors
using the abandoned farmland that's
turning up all over and so as the Oryx
comes back it will repopulate these wild
lands and make them more bio diverse by
opening them up with species rich
meadows surrogacy Moff is probably the
biggest ecosystem revivalist there is
out there in northern Siberia he is
working with
the realization that they're the largest
biome in the world used to be what was
called the mammoth steppe reaching a
hallway around the poles where there's a
lot of land and it's now mostly boreal
forests and an tundra but back in the
day it was grassland kept that way by
mammoths and by other large herbivores
so sergei is bringing large herbivores
to this place he calls Pleistocene Park
93 square miles
there fenced where he is restoring the
original density somewhat like Africa of
these large animals and they are
treading the tundra down turning it into
grassland likewise the forest he began
at 1988 and it's well along you see the
wild akuti and horses in the background
their musk ox is in the foreground
Ranger and bison are being added he
wants some American Buffalo that would
be good
and he says he would gladly populate
Pleistocene Park what is the old
mammoths as soon as they're available as
he said recently to fight the forest
instead of mammoths we now use military
tanks unfortunately they don't create
Dongwoo National Geographic Illustrated
to what the Pleistocene Park will look
like once it's a safari ankle just this
morning I got an email from Sergei he's
buying land south of Moscow he's going
to start him or at me already is
starting a more accessible place to seem
park and it's already starting defensive
and inhabited with these creatures and
that one will be easier for us and
everybody else to visit part of what he
wrote me today is he says part of all
required animals I have found within
Russia but some will have to be taken
from abroad Oryx
bison move lawns Red Deer all these
animals lived on this territory in
Pleistocene also mammoths hyenas cave
Lions cave bears
humans so by the end of that private
meeting at National Geographic the
scientists realized that you know we're
ready to go prime time and we wanted to
get the subject of the extinction out
there in a ways with enough context so
the public discourse about it wouldn't
go all simple-minded but would stay as
complex as the emerging Sciences and
about that time Chris Anderson the Ted
invited me to give a talk at Ted this
year and then suggested and offered that
help to do a TEDx on de-extinction
which was organized by Ryan and we did
that in Washington DC this March
National Geographic again stepped up his
host
that's rather fabulous occasion got lots
of preps and really interesting
precedent is Bill Powell who talked
about the American chestnut it's the
only plant that's been discussed in
terms of this it hasn't really gone
extinct but there's an extremely loved
plant tree that was one quarter of the
eastern deciduous forest billions of
trees and I want to extinct over the
period of a fool 1918 1950 and
depauperate in the entire area so
starting in 1983 the American chestnut
foundation has been running a program to
cross the American chestnut with a
blight resistant because this fungus
came in from China that was killing the
trees and there was a blight resistant
Chinese chestnut so there's now the
fourth generation of selective back
reading and they're down to a fifteen
sixteenth American chestnut which is
pretty resistant to the fungus and
they're gradually being released to
repopulate the forest at the same time
Bill Powell working with Chuck Maynard
took a biotech approach starting in 1990
they are invited to by members of the
foundation and they observed that the
blight cankers do the damage with oxalic
acid how they happen to be genes in the
wheat
defeat oxalic acid they detoxify this so
when those genes were engineered from
the wheat in the American chestnut play
resistance and in fact the the first
version darling for you see here was
nearly as resistant as the Chinese
chestnut and the one that bill announced
in March
darling 311 is more resistant to the
fungus and the American chestnut and
this transgenic tree is also joining the
American chestnut revival one of the
things you have to wonder is can this
kind of technique be used against the
fungus that is killing frogs and bats I
think it probably can bill Paula noted
that when you back cross the American
chestnut this tree has 45,000 genes a
lot more than the we do and some 2800 of
those are coming from the Chinese tree
in the back Ross where's his transgenic
American chestnut there's only three or
six genes that are new to the tree and
they are put in there with introduced
with much more precision so this in his
metaphor is you know comparing 11 pages
of a book versus two or four words so
the question is are these tainted
species which is the tainted species the
one that is fifteen sixteenths American
or the one that is 99 and 44 Oh 100% 44
107 percent American just a little trace
of weak in it that kind of question is
gonna keep coming up oh one of the
really loved guys here was Alberto
Fernandez arias told the landmark work
they're doing with Spain's Picardo 1990s
there was just one left this female
named Celia because they knew there was
just one left they captured her
temporarily and took a little bit of ear
tissue and cryopreserved it and released
her to the wild again she was killed by
a falling tree
and a couple years later in 2003 they
took that frozen tissue made a clone to
egg basically a twin of her implanted it
in a surrogate mother goat the pregnancy
after many efforts went to term and a
live baby Picardo was born sometimes
this is still early stages of the
process this one only lived for ten
minutes but the techniques are moving
right along this was the very first the
extinction and if you want to ask what
the what extinct animals the first
likely to be brought back I will bet you
that it is the Picardo and the Alberto's
team will do it working with George
Church and Bob Lanza and others Mike
Archer focused on the thylacine many
years ago and now he's focused on one of
the most exotic animals in the world the
gastric brooding frog this is a frog who
laid the eggs and she swallowed the eggs
turns her stomach into a uterus the eggs
become tadpoles and a little baby frogs
and then he opens her mouth and baby
frogs come out how the hell does she do
that
is there anything in that technique that
we might want to know in terms of
dealing with ulcers or something that is
a lot of medical information to be
gained but they went extinct in 1979 but
one was frozen and was found in the
bottom of freezer that wasn't crying
served it was just down there with the
ice and whatever but and what they'll so
they've tried cloning this frog and
they've had amazing success try and try
and try finally got to where it's now at
the blastula stage this was announced in
March is a big deals in the newspapers
of him got the whole frog back I haven't
got it to where it invaginate sin the
gastrula stage and it started to make a
structure but to get it this far as a
bloody miracle and a sign that they'll
probably be able to bring the gastric
brooding frog back that may be the
second one that comes back all this has
a lot of this has to do with
cryopreservation and Oliver Ryder down
to San Diego at the frozen is who is the
master of this because for 35 years he's
been preserving tissue from endangered
animals at minus 196 degrees Celsius and
at that temperature cells stay viable
the DNA stays intact and viable and you
can work with it it's not ancient
fragmented DNA so a species like the
northern white rhino which has no
breeding pairs left we just heard from a
group in Kenya would like to work with
us on this using the variety of DNA
Rhino DNA that's there in the frozen zoo
some cloning techniques this species
should be able to be brought all the way
back and indeed Oliver has already shown
that they can take the skin cells
fibroblast
from his frozen tissue and get it to be
induced pluripotent stem cells from
which you can make almost anything
IPS cells of the magical material of
genomic creativity so then we come to
Bob Lanza chief scientist at advanced
cell technology he took a what was it 25
year olds
of an endangered cattle called the Javan
Banting and cloned it and planted it in
an ordinary cow and brought forth a
healthy job and Banting who thrived
that's a measure of how far this
interspecies cloning is moving along now
what really excites Bob Lance is the
capability now and I want a Nobel Prize
last year for Shinya Yamanaka of taking
fibroblasts skin cells turning them into
juice induced pluripotent stem cells and
from those you can even make germ cells
sperm and eggs and that could be used to
bring back all sorts of endangered
animals but you know I'm still wrapping
my head around this because males can
produce eggs females can produce sperm
gay parenthood will never be the same
pretty quickly gay parents the other
female can go he hasn't they have their
own genetic children now if the gay male
couple will have to borrow somebody's
uterus but that's what's coming pretty
interesting stuff by the way Lancet also
says he collects huge dinosaur fossils
and he says unfortunately we won't be
able to bring dinosaurs back because
they're 36 million years old and you
cannot clone from stone here's Mike
McGrew from the Rosalind students
Scotland his money slide is a picture of
a father duck and it's child a baby
chicken
Mike's colleagues in Dubai persuaded the
embryo of this duck wallet form to have
the gonads with a chicken so when the
duck grew up it was chimeric and it's a
doc all right with the only eyes of a
chicken's oh and I made it with it
you're gonna produce the chicken okay
that's suppose you take an endangered
Falken or there's a bird and Dubai that
people are interested in and persuade
the gonads of chickens to be a male and
female to be Vulcan gonads out of those
chickens you will get Falcons it hasn't
happened yet but it's you know the
science is clearly there and the
engineering just needs to be carried out
real Falcons from just slightly doctored
chickens
so you can see that this will lead to
getting passenger pigeons if we need to
go that route we may not need to the
question keeps coming up are these
painted species is there something wrong
is the passenger pigeon got taint of
band-tailed pigeon if it goes through a
technique like this
Kent Redford has been the chief
scientist of the absolutely wonderful
Wildlife Conservation Society for quite
a long time and he says we're getting
way too purist about these genomes most
of the American bison that we protect
out cattle genes in them they can't tell
it by the look they behave just the same
they fight alpha wolf and they last
through the winter without freezing
selling they have some cattle genes so
what while wolves consort with dogs and
pick up dog genes on their own out of
curiosity or interest or boredom who
knows well they do it wild coyotes
somewhat more cleverly in their travels
to the East Coast where they're more
whitetail deer than you can possibly
have been picking up wolf genes along
the way I sailor can I borrow some of
your genes and they can now take down
young whitetail deer and the Gardeners
of the East Coast are not sorry about
this and in fact the animal has turned
itself all by itself into a somewhat
different animal they now refer to as
the eastern canid so Redford says don't
stress too much about genetic purity and
then he said something really
interesting
I believe that my chosen field of
conservation started off with a
conviction that it was a crisis
discipline and that it could only get
people's attention by pointing out what
is wrong and the terrible things that
were doing to the natural world I think
that after 30 years of that people have
stopped listening to us and I think that
the lesson should be that hope is the
answer and that hope will get people's
attention and
why I'm less concerned about the details
of de-extinction than I am about the
lesson of hope that it can carry so
fantastic outstanding thank you here
well the intent of the TEDx the
extinction was that word would go forth
and people would hear about the idea of
the extinction in respected I have to
say it worked it was a cover story in
National Geographic it was front page in
the New York Times there were two
articles in science magazine hundreds of
other places online and other
publications New York Times asked me to
write an op-ed piece about the
extinction which I did and they accepted
and then they didn't want to use it
because they felt it had been scooped by
this front-page story so they didn't
turned it back to me and I just put it
up on Huffington Post and which was
surprisingly easy and quick in rewarding
converges going through the op-ed etre
anyway up it went and then the great
thing is you get he put something up
then you get to do science on the
commentary so here came the comments and
I thought there is an alarming theme and
there people think that nature is broken
hopelessly broken and this is a piece
where I detailed how there is habitat
waiting for the Great Auk for the
passenger pigeon for the woolly mammoth
but they said none of these animals will
ever be any more than zoological
curiosities the world they inhabit is
gone sad the true actually not true
there are natural habitats if not all
you were destroyed as quickly eroding
mmm that's true in a few places but in
most places it's the opposite there's a
recent paper by Jesse ossible and others
in his titled peak farmland you have now
peaked at farmland and more wild land is
coming every year one of the comments
was the human race is stripped over 40%
of the world's jungles and forests and
last 100 years there is absolutely no
point and bringing back
animals or do they leave out is that
second growth of these forests is
greatly outpacing the rate of the orders
being cut down so the question is and
this is Kent Redford's question what is
the cost to conservation of this kind of
hopelessness so one of the great tools
for wildlife protection is the red list
of endangered species compiled by the
IUCN it's a crucial compendium of bad
news
and it lists B but there they've been
listening to Kant Radford and they're
working up on now doing a set of green
lists and the green lists will list
species they're doing really fine thanks
and species that were in trouble like
the bald eagle that are now doing a
great deal better thank you everybody
they're also going to be listing
protected areas in the world that are
particularly well managed
congratulations to them and keep up the
good work so these are signs that we've
sort of to blend it in with something is
that conservationists are getting the
idea of building hope and building on
hope and they see the extinction as part
of that you know one of the founders of
conservation biology is stand temple and
he said in Washington de-extinction is
essentially a game changer for the
conservation biology movement it changes
one of our principal arguments that
extinction is forever protect some
endangered species might be diluted it's
not just a matter of competing for funds
though they worry that might happen
people might say hey extinction is
curable we can relax about these
endangered animals won't go we'll fix
their problems later maybe that would be
like giving up on exercise and good diet
because you hear the cost of heart
surgery or going down
the extinction you must be catching on
is really hard and expensive and doesn't
always work it's better to keep the
animals from going extinct the first
time so for geek things to go ahead it's
really got to blend in with the
conservation efforts to prevent
extinction it might help you bring back
some iconic superstar extinct animal and
bringing back its habitat and the whole
story of getting its world back was
going to protect a lot of other
endangered animals in that habitat and
as you can see here Stan temple likes
the idea of bringing back what he calls
extinct alleles from the museum
specimens and from the frozen zoo
specimens of these animals that are
short on genetic variety and are not
reproducing well here's a landmark
Hendrik poinar is ancient DNA expert in
Canada and this is the dahle mosquito in
amber that was shown by his father
entomologist George pointer to michael
crichton who wrote the book that became
the movie Jurassic Park the idea was
there might be some dinosaur DNA in that
mosquito there's not
not nice try but it's great movie and it
got a lot of people used the idea that
you might be able to bring back some
extinct species wondering for sure that
we should be able to bring back it's a
fabulous pervert preserved DNA is the
lowly mammoth and as Hendrik pointed out
from their DNA you learn that not all of
them were woolly they varied originally
they hybridized during their declining
millennia because people thought well
you know climate finish them off not
likely because they lasted through a
great many ice ages and interglacials
and all of that and there were some of
them actually around at the time the
Egyptians were building the pyramids
what did the men there was people with
Spears oh I would love to see us move
ahead with reviving woolly mammoths and
I'd like to see this become the totem
animal for the long now foundation along
with our totem art project the 10,000
year clock a baby woolly mammoth which
is a lot bigger than this to get a
female and for her now to produce
another baby first she's got a sexually
mature for 16 to 18 years she gets
pregnant then she got a just ate for
nearly two years so you're talking about
20 years from generation to generation
captive breeding the zoo's people will
go and see them and enjoy them and then
finally getting him back in the wild
maybe by the end of this century but I
hope that we'll be on the case all that
time the youngest scientists at the
gatherings was Ben Novack pronounces it
shook loose a lot style and
because the genomic technology had been
covered he was asked to talk about how
do you get from the cell to a burden
from the bird to a flock and he's a
former student of Henry Point ours
he'd been obsessed he said since he was
14 years old and did a blue-ribbon
science fair project on bringing back
the dodo I was at Antonis that dodo was
a pigeon big pigeon and by the way it
there there is some DNA left from and it
it might be brought back somewhat later
probably eventually he focused on the
passenger pigeon and he showed that the
work that he is doing nail them the main
thing we'll be doing is sequencing the
band-tailed pigeon the passenger pigeon
and exhausting detail comparing the two
genomes looking for mutations if they
parted company six million years ago
there's a fair number of mutational
differences between them to make the
birds the different birds now a lot of
those mutations will be silent maybe
that's really most of them but some will
be crucial like one he's showing here
that makes it's a coding gene that makes
a different protein that one you
probably want to be sure it gets from
the extinct bird into the genome of the
living bird now then you get to an
interesting situation which is everybody
worries well well what are these things
going to do they don't have been they
don't have passenger pigeon parents they
might have band-tailed pigeon parents or
they know about how to be a pastor Peter
well it turns out that the passenger
pigeon parents a hatch the egg mother
and father of the pigeon milk feed the
squabs for about 14 days and then before
the squabs even fledged all in one day
this huge former square miles with
pigeon salt well go and the squabs are
there and he's got a platform like this
and not able to fly yet going hello
what just happened how do I be a
passenger pigeon figured out kid um
it's apparently mostly in the genes and
Ben is pretty sure that what happened
this is and you get this from some of
the historical record is that the birds
do fledge and there's a cohort of them
you know first walking around the ground
then flying and there's a gang of
juvenile now flying passenger pigeons
and when a flock of adult passenger
pigeons go by they go oh that's what
you're supposed to do and go off and
join the flock and then they're part of
the deal passenger pigeons are highly
opportunistic they do not migrate from
one place to another they go basically
to where the food is and they travel
with the seasons a little bit so the
possibility that they're not hardwired
is they need to be to get to the right
place Ben figures they could you could
train up some homing pigeons that will
flock and then guide these young
passenger pigeons to the right places
until they catch on and the wild teaches
them the real story and Ben ended with
something I really like seeing something
he thinks is essential which is he says
conservation focuses so much in the past
but what you want is images of the
future that you're trying to create
because conservation really is about
improving the future now there's a model
for all this some ways even better than
the American chestnut and that is a
animal that looks like it for sure one
extinct the California condor this is
Michael mace from the San Diego Zoo
pointing out that the California condor
swing span is three feet wider than he
is basically nine foot wide will Hearst
refers to them when you see them coming
at you looks like a b-52 Jose if he's
level wings and they nearly did go
extinct in 1987 there were just 22 left
and everybody figured they were gone but
San Diego Zoo in Los Angeles to do the
captive breeding program here
you can see these birds were around when
the mammoths were in California and the
mammoths were probably one of their
major food sources so the san diego's
who has a mammoth skull for this guy to
pose with one of the things that you can
do with captive breeding is besides
increasing the population of the animal
you care about you can train it to know
certain things about the modern world
and these snails such as that power
poles can kill you and so at the San
Diego Zoo they have power poles that
will just shock you and not kill you and
that the birds squatted in the wild and
they know better than to land on power
poles so they're now over 400 condors
half of them in the wild you can see
them down at the pinnacles and Grand
Canyon or as here along the Big Sur
coast this is what seeing extinct
species back in the world would be like
so long now is pushing ahead with the
passenger pigeon
we've been he is joined Beth Shapiro at
UC Santa Cruz and their brand-new
ancient DNA lab they are sequencing the
band-tailed pigeon they're doing much
more refined sequencing of the passenger
pigeon starting the process is comparing
them meanwhile our close allies George
church and Bob Lanza George just got
some mammoth DNA from our sorry elephant
DNA elephant DNA from the frozen zoo to
see if he can make induced pluripotent
stem cells for Lent Novak our Novak sent
fantail pigeon egg to bob Lanza who
working with the embryo is seeing if he
can make induced pluripotent stem
cells from the embryo cells mike McGrew
is on call if we need to use the Roslin
dr. chicken technique and the cool thing
is that people start showing up
we just got email a couple weeks ago
from David Oller who is director of
animal collections at the Cincinnati Zoo
the place where Martha died a hundred
years ago and they have the aviary where
she died there is a passenger pigeon
Memorial and an owner wants to do is do
the captive breeding the passenger
pigeons there and the released in the
wild of the birds back into the Midwest
where they used to live and he's already
working now with Ben Novack to get
band-tailed pigeons they're in the zoo
then start the process with those guys
of having a pigeon flock building once
again the Cincinnati Zoo and the ideas
martha's equivalent will come out of
there soon enough
so as these techniques mature and the
costs come down and that always happens
with biotech they should be applied to
you know grow across the board use the
techniques once we got them for the
Carolina parakeet for the Great Auk the
Heath in for the ivory-billed woodpecker
everybody wants that the eskimo curly
was a wonderful book about that the
Caribbean monk seal for the woolly
mammoth yes please because the fact is
the last 10,000 years humans have made a
huge hole in nature and now we have the
ability to repair some of the damage
most of the repair consists of expanding
and protecting wild lands and expanding
and protecting the populations of
endangered animals which will then be
joined by we hope extinct animals
because some of these animals some of
these species that we kill off totally
we might consider bringing back into a
world that misses them thank you
[Applause]
well let me introduce to you the stage
Ryan Phelan who is the executive
director of revive and restore and Ben
Novack who is personally responsible for
bringing back the pasture pigeon good
luck and Kevin Kelly who will be the
Inquisitor of all the awkward questions
he's been collecting from you thank you
[Music]
asked to remind people that there is a
reception after this on the second floor
along now reception so please join us so
there are a lot of great questions and I
think the the first one is what would
you say surprised you most about this
project compared to the many other
projects you've done in your life
there's always a point where you're kind
of you have this conception the moment
you imagined the woolly mammoth coming
back into the sub area and other things
the passenger pigeon but what what
didn't you expect as you started this
that you've already learned in the first
year or two that you've been doing this
what's been the biggest payoff that was
not in the original vision we didn't
have bringing back extinct ease
ecosystems in our mind at all and the
fun thing about doing projects like this
is the people who show up like Ben or
like Sergei seem off who just say oh
yeah I wanted to do something like that
or I'm already doing something like that
or I've been doing it for 35 years like
all of her writer
and you know these things that you raise
a flag and you never know what's going
to rally around it if the people
assembling on this thing are some of the
most interesting people you can imagine
so Ryan you've done a lot of things a
lot of projects like this one of them
was the all species which we did
together how is this one different I
mean one of the questions I would have
is is this reviving the extinction is it
inevitable what would we get there
anyway is is this is this something that
you need to push on really hard right
now
when went biotechnology is kind of
eventually what we be doing this anyways
is necessary that we do this really fast
to gain a few years in doing this I
think the answer to that really has to
do more with the fact that we're losing
so many species right now and the
technologies that are going to be used
for de-extinction
will be completely translatable into
conservation practices so the species
that were Stewart mentioned the
black-footed ferret and the northern
white rhino these are species right now
that you know could be potentially
extinct in the wild
I think the northern white white rhino
actually is and utilizing these
technologies is going to make a huge
difference so you don't want to wait too
long it's it's a little bit like saying
the same thing with in vitro Stuart's
first question was well when is it right
to actually push the science into the
into the marketplace and yeah we could
have just waited on in vitro for another
20 years but some of us wouldn't be here
so give me a little bit more of a vision
of what I guess a 100 years from out in
terms of long hello now vision of
generational or two from now and this
kind of technology is prevalent people
are doing in their basements in their
garages everybody can just the extinct
species if you want what what how does
that really play out into the
conservation how would you bit us
biotech really changed the world of
conservation in a couple hundred years
what what do you see I'm I'm persuaded
we've got about ten years to establish
they're sort of responsible way to do
the extinction mmm-hmm and if it isn't
set in place before you actually have
the extincted creatures coming out of
people's garages or some random place
and then people freaked out over them
and the conservation biologists are sort
of catching up and all the rest of this
if it can move forward in a well thought
through in the public discourse in a
really transparent way early on then
when you get to the weird stages later
on when there's people in their garden
shed trying to make one-eyed one-horned
flying purple people eaters which they
will they'll know that that is a
different thing to do than bringing back
extinct species which will be already
established is that you you know you
really honor the existing highly evolved
animal and that you have a code of
ethics about how you bring species into
existence I mean I think what Stewart's
talking about is not so much people
doing D extinct ting in their backyard
but using very low cost absolutely in
the home office so to speak desktop
publishing those species and creating
all kinds of hybrids breeders cat
breeders pigeon breeders have been doing
all kinds of weird mashups to date and
this these technologies will be enablers
whether we like it or not and the
question again is creating some kind of
framework to do it in a responsible way
how many kinds of weird pigeons have
been bred by now let's see throughout
the last several hundred years there are
something about between seven and eight
hundred registered different breeds of
pigeons some of which are not bred
anymore some are extinct
and what few people know about pigeons
is actually highlighted in the Origin of
Species is that pigeons actually display
far more phenotypic diversity than dogs
and cats or any other type of
domesticated animal all the way to the
number of vertebrae in their neck
certain things that never change in a
mammal you can actually breathe
differently in pigeons and so what does
your victory state look like then in
terms of this ubiquitous technology
would I mean would we have Jurassic
park's not with Dinosaurs but with a
pail of Palestine a Pleistocene Park was
is that sort of what we would get to
where we're just gonna fill up and bring
back as many extinct species as possible
or do we just want to bring back only
the ones that humans killed because
here's a question from Michael I think
it's Michael M no here's Emma isn't
extinction a natural part of evolution
would reviving extinct species disrupt
the ecosystems that have developed to
replace it
alright I've addressed this question a
couple times some journalists and even
some grade schoolers which the way the
grade schoolers frame it is actually I
think one of the best ways which is what
well they just have this deep look of
concern over horrible things happening
they still have this sense that nature
is like the outdoor version of their
pets and so they're very worried about
these things on bringing back hurting
everything what I have to say is it this
question has several points that have to
be weighed in one is it's a little
difficult right now with the state of
the technology to start putting
limitations on it because of how many
limitations already exist
the elephant bird of Madagascar might be
an amazing bird to have back in
Madagascar but if you head over to the
cow atomy of Sciences they just so
happen to have an egg of the elephant
bird next to an ostrich egg and it's
impossible for any living bird to lay
the egg of an elephant I could recreate
its entire genome all for naught that's
gonna be the same way with giant ground
sloths I hate to rain on anyone's parade
man but I can hold a living ground sloth
in my arms and a giant ground sloth is
20 feet long we can't get DNA from
anything over a million years old and
that's if it's been frozen really well
the whole time really our our window of
opportunity is the 200,000 year range
with with some confidence we might be
able to extend a little farther back
well it's that all that's kind of
interesting what's that oh that's
interesting
saber-tooth cats we get those oh yeah
yeah cliff cliff to dodge these huge
armadillo clips well once again what's
gonna give birth to a glyptodont well
I'll use pigeons I love pigeons I think
that should be obvious by now within the
last ten thousand years the fossil
record shows us that there are about 50
extinct types of pigeons
we have tissue and museums actual soft
tissue rather than bones of about 10 of
those 50 some species we'll never be
able to work with because we never kept
anything of them there's an actually an
extinct type of pigeon in which its
existence today in our knowledge is
based on a painting and a journal entry
no one ever kept anything and so you
know I can't bring back that bird I
can't bring back the dodo unless I can
get enough of its genome to figure out
how to make one and so when we start
applying things like well is the habitat
there that's a major consideration we
care about it's a limitation like
why bring it back spend all this money
for a zoo animal you know is what's the
point but if you can say yes there's
habitat does the extinction reason
really matter and this is where it's you
know it's a it's an odd question because
if the habitat destruction is what led
to the extinction but the habitat has
been revitalized then you can bring it
back
what if bringing back that animal is
what actually will revitalize the
ecosystem such as manit's on the steppe
and the weird thing is that no one I I
meet really understands is it is nearly
impossible to say that any extinction in
the last ten thousand years has occurred
independently of the expansion of human
beings on this planet I can think of one
the Saint Martinique giant rice rack it
apparently they tried to kill it and
when they couldn't kill it they turned
it into a French delicacy that they
cooked it was it was the size of a cat
and then a volcano went off and killed
everything on the island except for the
one guy they had in the underground
dungeon it's it's a fantastic story and
a lot of the ecosystem there was enough
of it left that it came back there's
never been a giant rat seen again these
are rare instances most species in the
last 10,000 years have gone extinct due
to humans so you're gonna have a hard
time finding an animal on the list of
animals that qualify for being brought
back that we didn't cause the extinction
of okay great that's a good question so
Michael M has a question in terms of
bringing back these species we have this
focus on species species he says how
important is it to think in terms of
bringing back species as opposed to
designing the best new hybrid species or
when those why try to bring back the
pure thing why not just go for this make
as many hybrids as we possibly can are
we limiting our options based on
nostalgia like the ways this guy
how because I think one of the things
that we're going to be looking at is are
there things that we want to engineer
into the species that we do want to
bring back so could you make island
birds resistant to avian flu which is
wiped out so many of our island birds
are there things Stuart mentioned the
gastric brooding frog
could it be brought back resistant to
this particular fungus so I think we
will see tweaks like that and we are
seeing conservationists now talking
about how certain species should work
with climate change at different
altitudes so theoretically you could be
bringing in genetic variation that that
is more you know receptive to climate
change so that may be part of what this
vision of say ubiquitous technology
would be where we're just creating many
many many more species not just the ones
that are reviving the the the extinct
ones but just creating every possible
hybrid we could be different species I
think they all have different different
alleles that will provide them with some
other traits but I don't think it'll be
a different species but that probably we
could do that so rich early says isn't
the DNA in the nucleus only half of the
story what about the cellular structure
of the egg maybe there's a lot of
technology that could go into again
engineering the donor receptive wombs
the eggs and the necessary part of that
so that could be you're saying what
could birth x species well you could
also use genetic engineering to make
something just to hatch the other thing
so you have these scaffolding species
that are necessary just to get the
species that you want I think that's
what the chicken is I think that's how
they might have specialized chickens I
don't want to see the chicken that can
give birth to an elephant burger sorry I
do come on boy what are they calls for
there's a lot of scary stuff in this
field I gotta tell you you know it's big
bird well and and so we got to come back
to how are we gonna do this responsibly
Yeah right so right now we have a lot of
laws
say people having wild animals basically
you're on allowed to have wild animals a
lot of endangered species you're no
citizens almost aren't even allowed to
touch in a certain sense you're really
prohibited from handling or keeping wild
birds say that are endangered and so
what would be some of the kinds of
responsibilities that people might have
with saying the animal makes man you
know Mike Archer a unmentioned mason
mainly in relation to the gastric
brooding frog but he is a total
enthusiast for the thylacine for the
Tasmanian tiger and he said if you look
at some of the museum specimens of this
beautiful animal you see science that it
were a collar some of them and it was
illegal they have thylacine as a pet
back then because the government was
trying to exterminate them entirely he's
pretty sure there were kept as a pet and
that if that hadn't been illegal that
would have helped them survive he said
no animal that has worked out a
relationship with humans has ever gone
extinct and so it may well be that part
of the sort of peacemaking that we we
make with these extinct animals as we
bring them back and I'm sure it'll
happen with passenger pigeons is that
people are going to pigeon fancier
you're gonna want some and no that's
okay with us right I want to see
passenger pigeons in every exotic aviary
in the United States I want you know I
don't want this to be an idea of I'm
giving my bird to the world I want this
to be our bird as Americans as Canadians
who originally got to see it I I want a
future of the extinction that's not
about trying to move backwards to the
past but is about the idea of possibly
customized species and using biology
more in the application of our lives I
think the future is about quality of
human life and responsibility to a
future we have we as humans we change
the world more than any other entity and
it's
high time we start doing it responsibly
and consciously and this isn't about
necessarily bringing back a mammoth
because well it'd be really nice to
erase that gap the mammoth is an animal
that could change an ecosystem we're
talking about changing the world in a
way that we've never done before and it
comes to pets agriculture everything
those are all things that people have
intimate relationships with that we need
to change and we need to work with for
an expanding population and yeah if I
can give a passenger pigeon to some
young 14 year old version of me that he
can keep at his house then I don't see
anything wrong with that
Andy Isaacson suggests are rich with
some of these things like the mammoth
would be that mammoth burgers would be
if myth burger turned out to be really
the best burger in the world then you
know you can make it without killing a
mammoth in fact you can probably make it
without reviving a mammoth because you
know mammoth tissue is so well preserved
in the permafrost I think we want to
have an admin guys who are starting to
need it modern meadow and so on I've
already talked to them about this they
said we'll start with leather can we
make mammoths leather jackets first and
yeah sure why not
mammoth burgers mm-hmm all of that
prepares people for the mammoths I guess
so you've been constructing this as a
very positive thing is is uses
conservation to create to make hope this
is the what can possibly go wrong
question yes possibly go wrong so what
what are you really worried about
philosoraptor you remember that the the
best line really in the movie Jurassic
Park is when the colon character says
which I think was based on the Stuart
Coughlin at Santa Fe Institute he's the
Kaos guy right he says um life will find
a way and that's what we're gonna keep
rediscovering and at the same time we'll
be beating our heads bloody trying to
make some rut calcitriol animal from get
it to survive and just won't do it
things like that occur at every level of
this process other animals will be sort
of you know long off they go now there
is a fear out there that there's gonna
be a mongoose in hawaii phenomenon or
the brown tree snake in guam phenomenon
that somehow nature is extremely fragile
and that some particular entity gets
loose with who knows what gene in there
and they take off and just world and the
human you Burris will think we know what
is appropriate to put where right and
put it in the wrong place right that's
the other part of this story right you
know the hard part is gonna be getting
these things to survive in the wild the
zoo is such a cushy place for an animal
that you try to push them out they say
no are you kidding
I'll live half as long I'll be hungry
most of the time I'll never find a mate
there's no doctors out there you know
what it's like to live with them I mean
you cannot get animals to leave the zoo
it's really hard you have to train them
and all the rest of it so you know those
are the real issues I think we're gonna
meet
is actually getting these things to live
back out in nature whoo which is one
tough neighborhood for every animal out
there so then you kind of have invented
your job and is this sort of the first
of the first are you the first person in
an emerging field or is this a movement
is this is this a scientific discipline
and I also understand Ryan that you are
looking to hire employee number two
employee number two so project
coordinator project coordinator but is
this something that we're gonna find a
lot of people immediately are there
other more besides the people that
Stuart showed are there is this have a
name does this feel to have a name does
it have a journal Ben aren't you gonna
be the first PhD I don't know II don't
know you know you asked earlier how
what's surprising about this that's
different from other projects and I
thought to myself this is my first
project yeah I'm 26 I I I'm notoriously
bad with graduate programs so I I don't
know if I'll finish one but I'm slightly
too dedicated to the product and the
work to do well at school programs
anymore
and just before I really continue how
many people in here are under the age of
50 Wow good sign that's really good
that's a good sign I promise you if some
horrible accident doesn't take you away
beforehand that given your life
expectancy you'll see passenger pigeons
and that's because of this emergent
field
that's because of Ryan and Stuart
pulling this together and the other
people that have already been working on
the technology to develop in this into
this for years but you know to show you
how you know the technology goes fast
but building a field can be kind of slow
ancient DNA started in 1984 as a
technique it's not an actual field it's
a technique that's important to
distinguish it's a technique that you
can use to explore evolutionary biology
forensics all types of things and you
know to this day there's still only a
handful of people in the world that work
on it only a few labs in the United
States that do it and so yeah it might
be fifty to a hundred years before this
is really an established field that any
student can enter a program and do but
that's what makes the first projects so
amazing and adventurous and great to be
a part of is this is what sets the
premiere of this and I can't say I'm the
first but I'm really happy to be riding
upon the the wings of the people that
are making it with me do thank you
I hope I'm over 50 but I hope I can get
to see the passengers enjoy stick around
yeah stick around so do any of you want
to be resurrected from a little bit of
spit when you're after you're gone we
have friends that are working on Aging
and we'd like to just go back in time
not being d extincted you know get
younger this is this is gonna be such a
biotech century I think kind of like
that the last entry became a digital
century with it what seems kind of
exciting and amazing now will not seem
as exciting and amazing as other
astounding things going on a life
extension and all that kinds of strange
chef gay couples having their own kids
and the curing of diseases okay here's
how weird it's getting already in
Britain the new field bioethics council
said it's okay
for English children to have three
genetic parents by which they mean
there's a technique now where if a
couple is about to have a child and the
woman has her mitochondrial DNA is
distinct from her nuclear DNA
mitochondrial DNA as is curious diseases
and mitochondrial diseases are horrible
for children you would like to nip that
bud right now well it can be done and it
is being done medically in England where
she provides an egg and standard in
vitro fertilization technique and then
another woman provides an egg and the
nucleus from the mother's egg is
implanted into the enucleated egg from
this other woman that other woman's
enucleated egg with the nuclear DNA of
the mother has her mitochondrial DNA
which is completely healthy this is then
implanted back in the uterus of the
mother and that child is born with
mitochondrial DNA of this other woman
and the nuclear DNA of the birth mother
that's already getting pretty strange
Kizer in a sense chimeric humans now
being made in england legally it's just
the beginning it's just the beginning
yes i i've also made the distinction
that the thing about the tech team that
by technology was there was never an
extinction in biological world there was
always extinction most of the species
and then have ever lived are extinct
extinct and so what we're doing now is
basically we're making biology that
doesn't have extinction which makes it
sort of like technology so i think we're
at the beginning of the variety and the
speed that we saw in technology and
computers but with the wonder and the
complexity of biology so it's definitely
going to be a fantastic weird world can
I can't tell you that I'm worried about
yes oh good it I think the biggest
challenge
this quote field of de-extinction runs
is when it gets really pitted against
existing conservation or environmental
ethics or movement as such as you can't
do kind of genomic engineering on this
side and be a card-carrying
conservationist or environmentalist on
the other side and I think that what you
know through the job I see long now and
revive and restore in particular playing
is really to help you know blend that
that basically when you're protecting
and conserving an ecosystem or species
on the brink it's really no different
than really trying to help bring
something back that has gone extinct
then it really is one continuum and if
we can forge that you know that you know
make that bridge and allow people to
think that they don't have to be in this
kind of either/or situation I think it
would be really healthy well this is a
generational project and I hope that the
under 50 crowd here takes up this and
really execute what you guys have
started but thanks for the thank you
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you